mit traum jetzt im islamisch sicher
einfach man sowas gemüse wie es gott und
beste unserer was möglich ist
[Musik]
zumikon und david blitzer
seit den olympischen spiele in sotschi
in der schweiz ein begeben
ein fünfter platz hatte auflaufen lassen
der erst 17-jährige gymnasiast
plötzlich sprang in der halfpipe auf den
fünften platz
doppelpack perfekt die ihnen die regeln
sind ganz viel style elfmeter in der
luft darüber wissen darüber liegen so
das war eine sensation ich fass es
werden und ich dass es gerade logik der
farm hat definitiv unglaublich viel
nur wenige kann haben und ich kann
einfach mit mclaren fahrer und ich
glaube wirklich gefreut am snowboarden
ist einfach gut gelaufen das war ein
hammer danach kreuzbandriss im märz nach
den olympischen spielen das habe sie
zurückgeworfen
[Musik]
die entfernen wo das fließband überhaupt
in gespannt hat und mit n tv.de
fremdkörper bringen
für diese sind die verletzungen
abgeschlossen und aber damals gelernt
und weiß dass das nicht passieren wird
die verletzung am anfang völlig
verunsichert weil ich schon wiederholt
als sie den honig zum zweiten mal wie
das gleiche rückbank risse
das ist nun schon das leben am rand sie
relativ kleinen chart-erfolg merschitz
das darf nicht passieren
[Musik]
ich weiß was also passiert ist mit der
verletzung anders sieht dann habe ich
das halt das relativ gut wegstecken aber
ich versichert mehrere spart wer hätte
ich mich verletzt
vorsorge ist eher was sie ich bin aber
das weit über 40 rote platz holen das
schweizer start und dein handy relativ
sparte vor sich gehen und jetzt vier
jahre später ist so ich halte es der die
gurke welt zu kleineren und ich weiss
ich wollte bitte gut sie der
hauptunterschied ist einfach das ist was
ich mich selber unter druck setzt zum
wettergott pro forma und letzte mal habe
ich mich einfach ohne jegliche weitere
staaten und das eigentlich jetzt sofort
zieht und dann doch in der natur besteht
nicht
[Musik]
ich will jetzt hip hopper sollte bleibt
das motiviert mich
und so bin ich wer im eigenen wald und
kunde ganz alles mit was rundum passiert
mission teilnehmen
[Musik]
dort gab es über los
forstwirt der eigentor der letzte große
teilchen sie bevor es dann mit wegkommen
saison geehrt worden dezember fahren und
das ist so gut ist wo man vorher gibt es
eben einfach voll trainiert
ich brauche den basics und weiter es war
nicht vor ort zum trampolin klemmt dann
würde ich jetzt nicht schnell umsetzen
wie es läuft
momentan ist oder sich tricks arbeiten
ich weiß mit großer wahrscheinlichkeit
die richtige police ist nicht so dass
ich jetzt ein bewusster treckern sich
mehr oder sie haben im gesamten fahrer
arbeite und anderthalb vor ort lüge was
möglich ist was die urlaubsfahrt dazu
was gott mit gefühl und trumpfen die
macht kreis sehen wenn ich jetzt wieder
ein trägt die ganze zeit trainiere beste
dame und dann würde der plan überhaupt
durfte auswählen grund einer und dann
weil das welche biz verloren sie vorher
und aus wie der swiss habe ich es eben
nicht
als ich für mich selber die motivation
dass der us konkurrenz macht und es
macht also für mich ich freue mich für
sie warnt zirkusleuten an der sich gut
mit umso mehr auf annika bisher reicht
von und die andere das auch seehandel
findet wow cool
[Musik]
ich bin nicht so einig sein könnte es
gar nicht sondern freue mich trägt kann
das system mit der andere teil
die spritziger
nein stimmt viele pixel
wer trug in saas fee und der steig und
hat das sehr gute nachricht
[Musik]
es ist ja gut aber ich kann da of the
seas überspannt wird ihr von frau
martina und weil sie so letzte woche hat
es erst mal von der sache jetzt
technisch zerstört jetzt einfach für uns
aber ich bin etwas ganzes jahr mitfahren
einfach letzte woche von 6 nicht einfach
weil das gargut aber gleich so am
schluss spüre ich bin der anstrich wird
dadurch jetzt ziehe
kommen schlechte bis vorsorge und stimmt
von körper her aber ich glaube das ist
das ist auch egal wichtig ist kurz
körpergefühl häuser sport und man muss
schon sagen wenn es so viel sport macht
und so und sport hätten wir irgendwann
mal alles klar ist im ganzen team daniel
ritz bankrott oder und das ist stand das
ist normal
dieser markt für lose deinem zieht jeder
einfach wichtiger impuls geben und dann
merkt schnell dass das ewig gleiche so
halte ich es ist einfach schön aufstand
der ruhr sie und wieder begrenzt also
mit betreuter frau räder blog seiten
nicht immer mit dem teamkollegen
zusammen sie ja es ist so dass ich
solche rückzugsgebiet
wo die anderen tiere hat mancher frau
wird morgen jungs
[Musik]
die fronten
wir konnten den flug am löken down the
front
[Musik]
das ist große sich jetzt der fehler
gesehen oder gesehen was ich noch
verbessern könnte oder was ich bald nun
ist wieder alles gut ist und darum
nächste tag umsetzung haben ja so
schwierig so viel zieht die das in der
stiere die videos wobei ich mach die
augen zu
also sicher bis die begegnung als auch
in die videos verglichen und darum ist
zum teil auch ließ
[Musik]
wollte videos
hoch hat einen höheren stellenwert
es ist doch listing bord dass man
sowieso wieder vom hocker und wird kurt
koch und weil ich brauch mal wird es
besser sie wie ihre kollegen koch und
auch wieder der coach im presse weiß
dass einfach der coach des chefs was
kuchen und waffeln anbelangt von der
fahrer kann ich ganz cool und meisten
hochlagen hat das heißt nicht dass ihr
sohn sie wird der portugiese bauausgaben
probiere ich finde das cool mit ihm über
alle reisen mit der zange und habe die
schöne familie moment wo wir noch nie
richtig familie ersetzen
er war das natürlich nur es ist viel so
ist immer also danke
[Musik]
die helfer speziell ist so ein ort zum
vom sport und von anderen skater
überhaupt nicht und da versuchen im
training und sogar dieses echte
wohlfühloase topfit gesundheitlich so
fit wie noch nie in der vorsaison jetzt
gewaltig wie gut es ging und jetzt haben
die endlich mal einer woche wohl die
ganze woche die haben für ideen will mir
in zürich als nächster in ihrer werte
und dich nur schön dass ich so viel
ferien blöd ich seit ich hab mal eine
woche hier bin und hier sieht man zum
die zürcher heimat und wieder machen in
der familie spart mit soße und sogar
zwei gemacht dass sich sehr lange
tatsächlich als familie
es wird
in diesem fall völlig bedient ist
verfolgen
oh mein gott
ich hoffe sehr das thema und da freut
man sich doch eigentlich relativ wenig
der fahrräder vielmehr über das lager
vor ihnen und es ist schön zu genau dass
ich das wohnhaus liegt merkel weil ich
einfach dass ich selber der hai das wäre
es einfach künstlich da ist ja mein sohn
kann stark werden die stammtischen jener
größer als wenn er denn im fernseher
sind und die halfpipe aber geld und mehr
sind sie zum stil und und und können
direkt mit mach das das ist das ist für
die manchmal fast der härteste moment
natürlich sommer meinte wenn er denn wie
kriegst wird dies unterblieb league und
mehr sind so allmächtig da und wissen
nicht was passiert ist aber jedes mal
anders entstanden ist
es ist nie passiert ist für mich eine
freundin moment verlorene christus
diesen stellen dann müssen die weine zu
erzeugen
vielleicht muss ich halt sowie foren an
dass das eben alles herausgestellt dass
weißen etappe
[Musik]
also ist es passiert immer über alles
passieren und darum auch leben einfach
eine so richtig die richtig fühlen dafür
dafür galt dass zunächst das risiko ja
ja ja dass da eigentlich absolut person
ihres wahlprogramms kontrolliert
musicals nach abba war irgendwie das
passiert ja gott sei dank mit dazu
passen
[Musik]
ich fänds völlig falsch würde die chance
so und sohnemann israel die jetzt ja
jetzt haben wir nur noch so viele männer
bei dem großevent das wird die
vergangene will ich weitermachen und
würde mir also würden ist unfall nur
über die ausrede dass das würde mich ich
glaube dass wir mit von schnee belastet
und sowie mit mit frei
[Musik]
wenn die kopf richtig liebt durchaus
mehr mit der rest von die körperschaft
rumpf mithilft ist koordination
ich möchte zumindest linie detail
darüber zu meckern aber im kopf ist aber
nicht so einfach haben und im schnee wie
standortes anders viel ab oder sollten
wir die automatismen trampolin behalte
ich habe dann im schnee und dann noch
der schnee
[Applaus]
schon wenige mit denen öfter geschafft
so viel kunst turne ich wichtig weil
tracks werden
es wird immer mehr an das stylische
tricks wie kompliziert die tricks mit
viel reicher und das ist durchaus so
dass george selber sehen auf das seil
und das mit hold
[Musik]
hey
ich habe mich 100 prozentig dann am
olympischen spiele beeinflussen und gute
weltcup resultate und das ist ja das ist
das einzige ziel einfach richtig gut
der erste wettkampf und richtig gut die
liga start und das publikum mit riding
nur noch nie und das ist glaub die beste
ausgangslage
[Musik]
jetzt im monat lang mit thx sie und
alles was der trainer denkt man im
moment klappt besser zeit die erste
woche im kloster rocker wie zwei bussen
noch mit ihm ganz recht abfange hat emmi
ist wagen wir ihn nach costa rica dieser
woche bin und dann bin ich direkt die
tour sorgen komplimenten
das ist jetzt trainingslauf vor coppel
gilt auch vor der qualifikation sicher
super gefühl
so hätte die qualifikation zu überlaufen
und dann wäre wiederum die qual ist ein
so schlecht sich und den honig linie
fahren ja ich sage dass ich an
der staat kann
trotz rasant an und ich haben wir
einfach der druck so prüft der zweite
bekommt und von der schlechten zweiten
treffer
mega schwierige bedingungen zum fahrer
und dann war der letzte dreck befreit
und damit ist das letzte land irland
lettland
[Musik]
dann holte nach härter man definieren
und dann bin ich so bin ich allein punkt
noch freut hat zu mir zurück ins
schweizer a und block sei die ganze usa
attraktiver kampf spitze will bekommt
einfach dass eine gurke sind bitter
[Musik]
warum
ob ich habe mich sehr gut roest sie noch
so ereignisse und ich kann auch einfach
ich habe auch in berlin anbieten
und ich glaube das hat braucht
wenn ich genau wie hertha keinen schnee
ich wurde in reimen schnell kasse
[Musik]
apa
ich freue mich auf mit einem land wo es
dann sehr wichtige stimmen und das hängt
ganz viel harmonie einfach ein gutes
gefühl aufbauen und das ball meistens so
viel wie vor das kurz reinigen haben und
ja sascha wurster und weiß soll der ich
jetzt auf den stoff dran und da ganz gut
angekommen
für mein gefühl mit so wäre auch mit dem
selbstbewusstsein pauline drops dann
kommt meistens gut
hedge-fonds endlich los
[Musik]
irgendwie präsent und ich weiß das ist
das große ziel das ich die schweiz
repräsentieren spielen wenn ich darf mit
diva ist also viel schweiz dürfte start
dann
stieg natürlich eine große vorfreude das
einfach so größten sportler das größte
event im sport überhaupt eine
dementsprechende er ist fisch mit vor
frodeno weder falsch liege waren nicht
schon weiß dass wirklich so wie ich das
will ich sie für mich entscheidend und
ich noch andauern
die
ist
[Musik]